معركه وبخمود قد تنقل الروس الى اهداف
استراتيجيه اخرى والسيطره على السوليدار
هي الوسيله سته اشهر وعمر المعركه في
مخمود مرته بمرحلتين الاولى دامت المئه
يوم قاتل فيها الجيش الروسي التقليدي لكن
نتائجها لم تكن كما تريد موسكو اما
الثانيه سجلت نقطه فارغه في الحرب حين
تولت مجموعه القتال هناك باتت المرحله
اكثر دمويه استعنت فاجنر بسجناء ومرتزقه
وبعد دخول باكر اعلنت روسيا ان الهدف
الرئيسي لا تصل وليس محمود السيطره على
سوليدار تساعد اصلا في تطبيق محمود خاصه
وان الاوكرانيين مع خسارهم في البلده
جلبوا
مؤسسه شركه باكناري
المقرب من بوتن يريد اثبات ان شركته هي
الوحيده القادره على تحقيق انجازات عسكريه
بالاساس غير مقتنع عن بادا وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه واتهامها مرارا بالتقصير خاصه بعد
الانسحاب روسي من خطاب واستعاده
الاوكرانيين السيطره على خرسون يريد
بروجين الانتصار في بخموط وسوليدار لتعزيز
مكانته السياسيه في روسيا وهكذا تتحدث
التقارير الغربيه كما يريد ثروات المدينه
مدينه الملح وتقدر الاحتياطات هناك بنحوي
13 مليار تون نفر رجل هذا الامر لكن يبدو
ان عينه تقع على ما هو اكثر من ذلك
ايطالي